In fact, I have
presented the first time indeux-mille-vingt-deux
with ecology in the center,
that's it,
right?
So I'll explain,
I am a former Macronist,
okay.
And basically,
we diverged from the point of view
and we left with a little environmentalist,
uh.
Elsewhere,
okay.
And we landed,
that's it,
in 1 centrist and environmentalist party.
So we have
decided to run in the elections.
But we were still close
of Emmanuel Macron.
So we said to ourselves
that here it is,
we affirmed our majority
and all that,
but 1 greener project
than the basic project.
And then I'm campaigning in the Ardennes and they say,
ah,
I ask to be able to attend interviews.
I am told,
ma'am,
you have 1 limited speaking time,
I say, oh well,
how much?
They tell me 30 seconds ?
And I say
30 seconds a day.
Oh no,
for the whole campaign,
no,
if I had 30 seconds.
Results,
in fact,
the journalists told me,
you can come for an interview,
but I have to tell what you say,
oh yeah.
So I never had
no interview indeux-mille-vingt-deux,
on TV,
on radio,
except to say hello,
my name is Juliette de Cosan,
I am a candidate,
and then I had burned my 30 seconds,
oh yeah.
And so the idea is to,
What does it do? No,
so I didn't touch the chest,
I specify.
Uh.
So now,
indeux-mille-vingt-trois,
ah no,
but you will see,
I will
explain everything I did to each of the photos,
no, I didn't touch,
I didn't know that these were my main arguments.
But finally,
Here you go,
Juliette!
So,
deux-mille-vingt-deux,
I actually took 1 picture of myself old.
Okay,
there's 1 good one some time ago.
That's a crazy thing.
Oh yeah,
it works great.
There you go.
Then
the Lise,
he reads the program,
he reads the program.
So I say to myself,
well,
Well,
uh.
Great.
Except that I was alpagée because
as I was very active within the Macronie,
he knew what I looked like now.
So I say,
there is.
And then there is the official Macronist competitor
which in addition
gets horribly upset because it says
presidential majority with Emmanuel Macron,
which is perfectly legal.
Because before we do all this,
I studied all the creator code,
right?
Yeah,
you have to know that I personally am.
Here,
I studied everything because you have mentions
that you have the right to put other things
that you have no right to do.
The only thing I'm not allowed to do,
is to get naked.
There,
so I say right away,
for those who are waiting for 1 naked picture of me
on 1 poster,
it won't be my fault